all right good evening i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department i'm out here this evening to
brief you on a homicide investigation
that we are conducting in the 5000 block
of sage lynn
street which is a residential
neighborhood near the intersections of
boulder highway and tropicana i stress
the details that i'm sharing right now
are very preliminary but around 5 pm
tonight metro police responded on report
of a male who had been shot
inside the residence directly behind me
patrol officers arrived and they
observed a male who was deceased inside
the doorway the original details that we
were provided is that the suspect who
was believed to be
the son of the deceased
would was potentially inside the
residence that prompted officers to try
to get him to exit
and at that point notification was made
to our swat team who responded metro
swat officers cleared the residence and
discovered that there was no one else
inside the house other than the deceased
male the deceased male is a black male
in his mid 60s and at this point we
believe our suspect is going to be his
son who is a black male in his early
thirties
what we've learned up to this point is
that the suspect lives in the house
behind me by himself
apparently yesterday he was having some
emotional distress and called his family
his father flew out here from northern
california yesterday afternoon
late yesterday afternoon the family
tried to get a hold of the father and he
did not answer his phone and they could
not reach the sun either
that prompted the mother and another son
to fly to las vegas to check on both of
them that is when tonight the mother and
the son came to the residence and that's
when they discovered
the body of
the victim laying inside the house so
again at this point it is still very
active investigation our suspect again
again is believed to be a 30 year old
black male who is the son of the
deceased and we are trying to locate him
at this point so anybody who does have
any information i please ask you to
reach out to crime stoppers your
information is completely anonymous and
there's also reward money available so
with that i'll take a couple questions
if you have them so why didn't police
enter the house first
before
the family
went inside so the original details that
were provided there were some details
that could not be corroborated which
ended up being false information that
was originally provided so the officers
attempted to validate that information
and were not able to validate it at that
point that's why officers did not enter
the residence when they first came on
the original call any indication how the
victim died right now there's
the original
belief is that it's going to be
potentially from gunshots however we
have not val verified that we're in the
process of obtaining a search warrant so
we can get inside the residence and the
coroner will make that determination but
there is some evidence that does show
that gun shots uh were fired inside the
house clarification on the timeline here
neighbors are saying that police first
responded to this neighborhood like 3 30
today and then
completely left the area and then around
five o'clock the family entered the home
and they found the male deceased and
they believe that that male had been
there for some time so the information
that was provided originally to the
officers when the family got here there
was some information that was
we have learned has not was not factual
so that information was provided to
officers officers attempted to look
inside the residence to validate some of
the information that they were provided
when they could not do that there was no
exigency that the patrol officers were
able to make at that time to enter the
house it is after the officers left when
the family
entered the house and actually
discovered the victim inside the house
do we know if the suspect drove off
walked off
people should be looking for we we're
trying to find that out right now
there's still like i said a lot of
moving parts the vehicle his vehicle is
still at the residence so we're still
trying to figure out how he left the
residence
is the family saying that he had a
history of mental distress mental
illness the family is stating that there
is a potential mental illness issue i
don't know if he's been diagnosed with
any mental illness but according to the
family he does have some mental problems
do you have this description on the
suspect
again right now until we can complete
the investigation and get in and
execute the search warrant i'll just
leave it with a black male in his early
30s do you believe the victim was killed
today or possibly yesterday do you have
any sort of timeline on that until we
can actually get inside the house and
the coroner can examine the body that's
going to be our next step so we don't
know from that flight from northern
california in uh into vegas do you have
a timeline on like when he actually
arrived in the city so we know he
arrived yesterday so then again
listening to the family after i believe
it was 3 p.m yesterday is when they last
heard from him so we don't have a
specific timeline after that
right thank you guys i appreciate it